,
CACES FOR
E  STATES FROMIS
TODAY.
RIES OF  P
AND HE DEFENDED BEIJING'TES OVEA
RELAONITH MOSCOW
WANG WENTPL
BEIJING TO FINS FOR
S RIGN
MINISTER'S TIGHTLY CONTROLLED
DE
>> Reporter: THOUSANDS O
GOVERNMEEGATESS
CHINA ARE GATHERING FOR THE
MEETINGS.
IT'S THE FIRST SINCEIT
ARE IL ORTCOVERING THE EVENT
BUED TO STAY OVERNIGA
.UARANTINE
HERAIN
HOTEL, WE NOW ADED TO TH
VENUE.EVERYTHING IS HIGHON
THE FON MES GETS
D OFF NMEN SQUARE.S VERYAR ACCE.
LY, THE TWO SESSIONS I
THE RARE CHANCE FOR MEDI CLOSE
RIGHT HEN  THE
MEDIA TRYING TO DOORIP YOU CAN
, A,ELY
SEPARATE FROM THE REST OF THE
O SENSS Y
CHOREOGRAPHED EVEN
THE NEW GOVENT SHAKEUPS TH
THE RUBBER STAMPT LLN HAVE ONEIL
STRENGTHEN XI JINPING AND THER.
EC EVENTS.TEL OF THEM.
INSIDE THE GREAT HALL OF THE
AS YOU CAN SEE, IT'S PRETTY
Y,S CLEARLY NOT AN
ISSUE OF
SOME OF THEVG TH
RTNS, INCL
THE FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE AS S.
HEINEVIT
WAGTS NOT CHANGE
APPROACH
CKLESS GAMBLE, ACCUSEDF CREA
PARTNERSHIP WI RUSSIA ASPERATIV
SUPPLIEDIA OR
>> SEE YOU AT THE TWO SESSIONS.
MEETING AS AN OPEN
JOURNALISTS CAN FREELY OPERATE.
SRI LANKA
>> THEY OFFERS S AN OPPORTUNITY
PUT QUESTIONS TO THE CHINESE
HESELSOUS RUN-INS
WITH TOP LEADERS LUKE THE D MIN
WE HAD A FEWO APPROACH
SOME D WHICH A A
CURAD
REPRESENTATIS.
FEELS HAPPTO HER NDSTRONGER.E FT
THE DELEGATE OUT BEFORE WEE
A CHANCE TO APPROACHTION IS HOWN
POSPA
POLITICAL MACHINE.TREMELOPAQUE
THISH
THMMUNIST LEADERSHIP ONLY
WORLD TO SEE
RR- S E IM, VICTORY.
NS O SURPRISING CTRY HAS AL
COMPLETELY OPENED UP, SO, IT
LIKE THOSE COVI
CONTROLS WREALLY JEXSESTRICT PRC
S  TWOIS
FIRST AFTER XI JINPINGECURED
CHIEF
ST
EV H GET AEDD  AS
IT IS A LARGAL
TITLE, BUT I A NEW SLATEMENT LED
S MA
E S E FOIRD
CENTER LIKE THIS.
AT DIDING.Y D
ESNFERENCE.
BEFORE T H THE
HE KY O THE S.
ACMPRED
DIPLOMATRYHEREHE MG
TS.
AT ONE POINT,  EVEMA F READING I
LI TD.OTE,EDSU THEE
IS HELD,HEAN TSAID T E CE EPORTG
S GOING TO DRAW THE IRE
BEIJING EA
JAKE?
>> ALL RIGHT, SENA
BEIJING, THANK YOU SO MU.O BRG
SENAIV O.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
WHEN HE IST IS
THE PEOP BY
THE OPWE DE UNITED STATES.
SER, DOEHIS LY COMBATIVE
RELATIIPINTHAT ILESS HOSTILE?D
THE NEW FOREIGN MINISTER'S
COMMENTS?
>> WELL, I KNORE
MINISTER, AND I THINK HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT TNITO PUMP THE B
THERE'S GOING TO B KCT, I K CHI
ONE THAT NEEDP
THE BRAKES.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN
S TIS
THI MEAN, OBVIOUSLY THE PANDEMIO
NEIGHBORS, WHETHER IT LITERALLYR
WITH INDIATH OF ANY
KIND OY ACY IN
E CRUSHING OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITO TH
UIGHU
STRAIT AND THE SOUTHNA SEA,  AN
YES.SO IS A REGIME T OWE ACTION
TOTS NEIGHBORS AND ALLROE WORLD
>>E SUBJECT OFREPORT TAIWAN'S
McN MINISTRYE O MEET WIT HOUSEAK
WARNED McCT TO VISITS POLEMEETI
CALIFORNIA.
WE DON'T KNOW. LIKELY
GO REACT.
ATT McHYE  TAIWAN,
IS
DO IT?
WE SHOULD REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THEN S NANCY PELOSTEND THAT WASO
PELOSI VISITED IACTUALLY LED A R
40TH
RTISAN GROUP OF NATORS, THAT'S
ACTUALLYSORRY,ST REPUBLICANS, L
EAKER, THE
GO CTED
TAIWANTH THAT INDIVIDUAL